you know if you personally have an
autoimmune disease or you know someone
who has an autoimmune disease
this video is so vitally important and I
think many times people give you advice
on what to do or even doctors or videos
tell you what to do based on maybe a
study you know you hear a study that
says well if you do this your risk for
autoimmune disease decreases by 50 or
whatever well that's cool but I want to
know why and this video is all about why
and it's about the pathophysiology or
the mechanism of how this disease is
created and it has everything to do with
several factors but a vitamin D
deficiency is at the heart of this
problem in fact some will say you can't
even get an autoimmune disease unless
you first have some type of vitamin D
deficiency in the first place which is
fascinating an autoimmune disorder
involves this perfect storm various
things that must occur at the same time
a vitamin D deficiency that would be
number one number two it's usually
triggered by maybe a virus or a bacteria
or another pathogen you can be exposed
to something weakening your immune
system like a vaccine you can also be
exposed to stress and the worse stress
is losses that's why there's a huge
connection between people who have
losses and then developing an autoimmune
disease and we also know a big part of
this originates in your gut because your
diet's not right that triggered the
whole mechanism and as an additional
thing you can have a genetic
weakness or susceptibility
to autoimmune diseases in general or you
could have a genetic weakness
with either the absorption of vitamin D
or the conversion of the inactive
vitamin D to the active vitamin D which
is very applicable to me because I found
out I have that problem I have a hard
time converting the inactive vitamin D
to the active form which explains a lot
of my history of having all sorts of
inflammatory conditions but thank
goodness I know enough to keep my
lifestyle in check to prevent certain
genes from kicking in and that's really
cool about this topic of epigenetics if
you really understand
epigenetics which I am including more
and more in my videos boy even though
you have certain genes that make you
susceptible to all these conditions you
personally can prevent all these
conditions from occurring you can keep
these genes turned off 100 percent and
all it takes is some knowledge and
that's what this video is all about so
it's the vitamin D deficiency that is
the most important thing in relationship
to autoimmune diseases now there are
many barriers to getting vitamin D that
go beyond just the genetic one that I
just recently found out I have if you're
obese you're gonna have problems
absorbing vitamin D if you have insulin
resistance okay you're gonna have a hard
time absorbing vitamin D if your skin is
a little bit darker you're going to need
more vitamin D to break through that
barrier and during the winter you're not
going to get vitamin D where you're
inside all the time it's becoming more
and more difficult to get vitamin D not
to mention as you age your skin becomes
thicker and you don't get enough vitamin
D alright so what is this relationship
between vitamin D and your immune system
being overactive when you think about an
autoimmune disease you think about some
crazy immune response that your body is
attacking itself it's generating
anti-bodies that means certain immune
cells that are against your own tissue
which is insane why would your body do
that there must be some massive
confusion well when we talk about
vitamin D what's unique about vitamin D
is that it controls your very complex
immune system it can either increase or
boost or decrease or suppress certain
parts of the immune system and when you
think about vitamin D suppressing the
immune system you might automatically
think wow I don't want to do that
because that's going to weaken my immune
system well just hear me out because
I've never met anyone who had a weakened
immune system by taking vitamin D and
you're going to learn exactly why now to
explain this I do want to bring up some
new terms for you but I'm going to
Define them so don't click off because
I'm getting too tactical but I think
it's really important for you to
understand this so in an autoimmune
situation where you have this
inflammation and inflammation is the
Hallmark of autoimmune this is why the
number one selling drug on the planet is
an anti-inflammatory and that just means
a lot of people have autoimmune diseases
as well as inflammatory diseases so when
you have this immune inflammation there
are several things that are turned on
okay and the first one I want to talk
about is something called NF k b and
without getting technical this is
something that triggers a lot of
information and it's part of the immune
system defense mechanism see
inflammation is there to help you well
in theory anyway and so anytime you have
an infection anytime you have an
autoimmune disease you have this nfkb
thing in active mode it's always turned
on when you have an autoimmune disease
or you have a cancer cancer tends to
spread into areas of inflammation
interesting in fact one of the new
strategies for treating cancer is to
block NF KB and this nfkb is triggered
by pathogens heavy metals
stress a few other things like oxidize
LDL which is kind of like the this bad
cholesterol that kind of can invade your
arteries that's just going to involve
inflammation and cause like the plaque
information and a clot in your arteries
but what's interesting about that
they're finding more and more that the
plaque in the arteries
his bio films filled with microbes so
what's probably happening is your immune
system is trying to kill off the microbe
and that's why it's there now this NF KB
thing that's creating all this
information is is coming from this big
cell called the macrophage and the
macrophage is kind of like the first
line of a defense mechanism where it's
going around and it's literally eating
pathogens and cancer cells and it's also
signaling other parts of the immune
system that turn on certain defense
mechanisms and one being inflammation
and so this nfkb thing
um it's kind of like the start of this
whole immune process right you have this
inflammation but then there's a Cascade
of things that are going to happen next
and most of them involve more
inflammation okay I'm not sure if you've
ever heard of the term cytokine but I do
want to bring that up because that is
part of this inflammatory process
cytokines are signaling communication
things that are involved with
inflammation and there's several
different cytokines that I want to talk
about because they directly relate to
the topic at hand which is vitamin D and
all autoimmune diseases and so let me
just first Define another word
interleukin inter means as a means of
communication and Lucan basically is
coming from a leukocyte which is a white
blood cell or targeted at a leukocyte so
interleukin basically is this
communication between white blood cells
okay so that's all you need to know
about that and so there's many different
types of interleukins there's like I
think there's 50 different kinds the two
that I'm going to talk about are the
interleukin or IL 1B which very
basically and simply is recruiting other
parts of the immune system it's like
saying hey I need more help in this
immune reaction okay so that's what a IL
or interleukin one B does and another
one which is an interesting one which is
i l or interleukin 6. this one also
recruits more inflammation more immune
help it's involved in something called
xeractive protein another
inflammatory protein but what's
interesting to me about this il-6 is on
my genetic test I have a problem with
this protein okay my genetics show that
I'm a hyper responder so when I have an
immune reaction I'm going to respond a
lot worse than the average person which
is
not good but it's good that I know what
to do about it this also explains a lot
that happened in my past like if I over
train I will end up with a lot of
inflammation if I eat poorly I will just
fill up with inflammation if I get
poison iuv I will react way more than
the average person but the cool thing
which is the whole point of this video
is that vitamin D turns this off okay it
just turns it off like a switch and
personally because I don't convert
vitamin D I need to take vitamin D in
much higher amounts than the average
person like at least 10 to 20 000 IUS if
not a little bit more per day but of
course I don't have any autoimmune
problems so I don't need to take
necessarily like 40 or 50
000 I use but 10 to 20 000 I use is a
good amount for me there's some other
things that you can do to turn off this
inflammatory process because if you have
an autoimmune disease you want to really
have a multi-approach to this problem so
omega-3 fatty acids cod liver oil it's a
must very very important as a natural
anti-inflammatory
but
omega-6 fatty acids compete with omega-3
so if you're just consuming omega-3
fatty acids and you're not eliminating
the omega-6 fatty acids
it's not going to work so you have to do
both okay this means avoiding certain
foods going to restaurants junk Foods
cooking with omega-6 fatty acids like
corn canola soy instead you could do
like olive oil cocon oil things like
that butter but make sure you do a lot
of omega-3 fatty acids here's the um
confusion a lot of people have with
omega-3 fatty acids they think if they
just take a little bit of it it should
knock out the inflammation really fast
well if you're deficient
in omega-3 fatty acids and your ratios
are not like a one to one okay realize
that a lot of people have like a ratio
of like 26
omega-6 to 1 omega-3 which they're so
far out of balance it's going to take
months if not a few years to
re-establish in your immune system in
your nervous system enough of the
omega-3 so you just need to make it part
of your new lifestyle and just include
it as a regular thing like a couple
tablespoons or if you get them in
capsules you know take a good amount of
that each day a couple other things you
can do curcumin is really important
reducing inflammation it even found
blueberries if you take a couple
blueberries a day you can actually
decrease this interleukin-6 there's
another cytokine that I want to talk
about okay and this is a interesting
thing because it's called a tumor
necrosis Factor basically it's this
immune protein that that destroys tumors
okay and viruses so as soon as the virus
invades the cell boy this tumor necrosis
Factor kicks in there and in the process
there's a lot of inflammation going on
and an autoimmune disease you have a lot
of this
tumor necrosis Factor
being generated and guess what what if
there's no pathogen like an autoimmune
disease like the pathogen is gone you
just have this immune reaction thank
goodness vitamin D is there to actually
turn things off now the last cytokine I
want to talk about is called Cox II now
maybe you've heard of Cox inhibitors
like aspirin is a Cox inhibitor it turns
off this inflammatory signal in the body
and again the original reason why you
have this cox2 is to help pathogens it's
like a defense mechanism this is why
with any reason you need Aspirin you
could very easily just do higher amounts
of vitamin D to turn it off but there's
some other really cool things you should
know about to inhibit or stop this cox-2
reaction from happening Mitaki mushrooms
are a natural cox-2 inhibitor
omega-3 fatty acids like the cod liver
oil as another inhibitor of the Cox II
hyper foreign which is a a compound in
Saint John's Wort inhibits Cox II in
fact
in certain studies it can work 18 times
stronger than aspirin for pain you think
of St John's Ward to help regulate
serotonin for depression but it also has
a potent anti-pain effect but don't
forget vitamin D if anyone has an
autoimmune disease and they're not
taking vitamin D good amounts of it
they just simply are very unaware and
they need to watch this video if the
doctor who is treating you for
autoimmune doesn't suggest this there is
a severe Gap in knowledge on the
relationship between vitamin D and the
immune system you should have them watch
this video now I've talked about vitamin
D being the off switch to a certain part
of the immune system okay there's
another off switch to just generally
your T cells okay and your B cells okay
that's another part of the immune system
and this is a very good thing in an
autoimmune disease because vitamin D
receptors are all over the T cells and
the B cells way more than this phagocyte
now so far I've talked about the
suppression of your immune system now I
want to talk about what gets activated
what gets boosted with taking vitamin D
there are three very powerful yet
ancient they go way back on the The
evolutionary track defense mechanism
these three things tend to surround the
pathogens and just poke thousands of
holes through there completely
obliterating that pathogen it's called
catholicidin another one's called ll-37
and the last one is called beta defensin
now these names are not important all
you need to know is it's another part of
the immune system that gets boosted okay
I mean think about this when you take a
steroid right for autoimmune disease all
you're doing is you're suppressing the
entire immune system but vitamin D
selectively turns things off but it
selectively turns other things on so
it's not going to weaken your immune
system so now you know the importance
and the significance of using vitamin D
for an autoimmune disease there's
definitely other things to do as well if
you haven't seen this video okay the one
on the gut health
like the thing that starts the whole
process in the first place I put that up
right here check it out